we are back again sorry for the delay
i don't have an excuse i'm just uh
i'm just lazy but uh here we go
i'm gonna accept my first challenge
it's gonna be a five-minute game so let
me just go
for the first five-minute game that i
find
it's much judging from the profile
picture that's me from turkey
and there we go move one e4
i'm gonna go to e5 now after ed5 i'm
gonna go knight of six
sacrificing a pawn in case white had
gone bishop b5 or
c4 now after my opponent takes on
on um
sorry just let me taken d5 like black is
usually fine
in this way and c5 this does not allow y
to put upon
d4 so in general
i think black's pretty happy with this
could it go on c4 while i had the chance
i elected not to
um yeah here's the question whether i
want to go for
for g6 or for e6 or e5
e5 feels a bit funky white may
then go f4 maybe
or even knight e2 and then
let me just go e6 trying to stifle the
bishop on
b3
castles castles 92 everything quite
normal
i guess knight will go to g3 at some
point
um in general a fairly equal position
bishop f4 is interesting claiming that
e5 is just a weakness
so that that's worth provoking you can
also go knight d5 for working in the
exchange but it feels like those
positions will be a bit
sterile
so i'll just go bishop d7 not an
impressive
developing move by any means but it
seems reasonable enough
and knight g3 very logical but now i use
the chance to get a tempo for bishop
for knight d4 now after reach bay 2 i'm
going to
deploy my bishop quite nicely on c6
now it feels like average exchange uh
sorry i've
achieved a fair bit and i should have a
somewhat better position
now after knight e2 knight d5 comes with
tempo
attacking the bishop on f4
d2 might happen
or b3
i think i'm fairly happy just to
to chop that one off on it on
on e3 don't love having to exchange the
other knight but
still i've got the bishop pair and there
are no weaknesses in my position
so i should be doing fairly well
now b4 that seems weird
seems to be free pawn to me and um
when i see three pawns being offered i
take them
otherwise my opponents have played a
very good game so far
now it seems that i'm doing well
c4 that's logical
[Music]
i think i'll just go a5 i could go
bishop c3
rook moves and then b4
but then my opponent would have made
maybe have some kind of play with d4
and those pawns moving forward so
i'm just gonna keep it simple
rooft one you know what now that my
now that my pawn is one square further
advanced
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna go for
bishop c3
now b4 a4 b3 it's hopefully gonna be
fairly quick and i think after
cb5 bishop a1 c bc6
bishop moves back to let's say e5 i
don't think my opponent will have enough
for the exchange
yeah there were some tactics there like
knight e4 could be tried
queen c7 attacking c6 and h2 if then d4
i would take an inch through king h1
h1 and take on c6 um
[Music]
the point is that i'm attacking the
knight on e4 and
uh yeah in case of queen of three i
could
go yeah i missed minute three whatever
we'll just uh follow the game instead um
yeah there were some lines there like d5
in that case ed5 bishop d5 green h6
i mean for like maybe queen of three
there could have fallen on
here also queen of three seems a
reasonable option
um and yeah my opponent is definitely
fighting
fighting well
e4 would threaten to establish two plus
bonds but then i could just take on c6
so that was not an option uh
here after r1 i think i just
invite the exchange of rooks
and all of these exchanges should just
um should in general just
lead me closer to victory probably gonna
is probably gonna threaten mate now
somehow
in lack of a better thing to do with
queen e4 queen h3
so i'm obviously just gonna protect with
with g6 and that's gonna be
that's gonna be pretty much game over
we have three back now we've got rook b8
attacking the bishop if bishop a2
there's rook b2
and um yeah this is um
this is going to be over well played
game by my opponent
um but in the end i think move 17 b4 was
the
culprit giving away a pawn for
for no apparent reason apart from that
my opponent played very very well
so now
bishop is lost and